Next we have Narcolepsy. This results from our brains inability to regulate our
sleep and wake cycles. This results in an irresistible urge to sleep and
occasions in which they fall asleep for several seconds to minutes throughout
the day. For example, a person with Narcolepsy might be in the middle of a
stimulating conversation and fall asleep on the spot. This disorder usually
starts in childhood or adolescence. You can imagine how potentially dangerous
Narcolepsy can be. Consider that a person with this disorder could be driving.
Working with dangerous equipment, or flying an airplane, or even riding a bike
and suddenly fall asleep. This can cause themselves or others serious bodily
harm. Here, let's look at this interview with a friend of mine who has
Narcolepsy.